it's all out there for the taking right
now if you have a gram of talent and an
ounce of hard work you'll run these
over and it's like it's true
like there is that the bar has never
been set lower whatever it is that
you're worried about think about how
fragile the average person is and
realize that half of the population is
more fragile than that taking the path
that everybody else chooses may seem
like the safe option but it's actually a
guaranteed route to a life that you
probably don't want I don't think
there's ever been a time where there's
been more opportunity and a lower degree
of
competition Chris it's so good to have
you on man this has been in the works
for a long time I'm glad we've delayed
it as much as we have because you are
absolutely blowing up man welcome to the
show thank you thank you for having me
it's really good to have you on uh
there's really a couple of subjects we
wanted to talk to you about uh the first
one of which is the reason you're so
successful um which is
mindset uh and you you're not only as
someone who works in your mindset you
also interview a hell of a lot of people
about how to be effective how to be
healthy how to be kind of in the zone
and many different ways so what have you
learned uh what can you share with us
and our audience yeah how do we get to a
million subscribers is what I'm saying
just the arms how do you get the arms
mate the arms is the easy part an
obsessive work rate yeah it's it's
interesting right so I got toward the
end of my 20s and didn't really feel
like I understood myself or the world
around me I think a lot of young guys
and maybe girls to feel this way they've
absorbed desires and goals that are
supposed to fulfill them and maybe
they've reached them or they're on the
way to reaching them and something
doesn't feel quite right so end of my
20s I've been on love Island you know
Blue Tick on Twitter free tacal
toothpaste all that stuff and I haven't
I haven't I don't know like it was a
promise that the world gave to me that
it didn't feel like it was delivering so
I realized okay some there's a mismatch
here there's something's up I'm doing
things that I'm told Will Make Me Feel
fulfilled and yet the Fulfillment
doesn't seem to be coming so it was a
fortunate time getting to read and
listen to guys like Alanda Boton from
the school of Life massively formative
for me uh Sam Harris Jordan Peterson
Rogan's show you know just real wealth
of of interesting individuals that were
talking about how the way you see the
world and the things that you go after
can change the way you feel and uh yeah
that I guess was just the journey the
mindset Journey that I've been trying to
get on because in my 20s I thought I was
depressed uh I had technically like
acute sadness for short periods of time
uh and I just thought that was the
texture of my own mind um I thought I
was lonely only child so always presumed
I was a lonely person and now I've got
to you know 35 and the texture of my
mind is unrecognizable to how it was
back then and the sort of friend groups
that I have and the support that I feel
and the enjoyment and the enthusiasm
that I have for life and the positivity
and the hope that I have around things
has also changed so I think you know the
proof is in the pudding that I went from
someone who was like not despondent but
pretty I didn't think that stuff was
like going that great and this was kind
of just life was here right and I wanted
it to be here and it just never really
seemed to wobble that much higher
actually I think you wanted it to be
here you wanted because you showed one
hand above the other actually I think
you wanted to be the real you that's
what I think that emptiness and and
vacuousness that you talk about I think
so many people experience that nowadays
especially in the age of social media
where kind of what you're supposed to be
is constantly being beamed into your
head Yeah by watching all sorts of other
people it's really interesting but I
will say this of all the people in our
space you were the first person that we
encountered who had a really healthy
mindset about being friends with the
people in your in your space instead of
seeing them as competition and we've
been good friends ever since I think
because of that well you guys have
brought this up on Rogan and I did as
well last year uh the difference between
us and UK culture right uh for the Brits
that are listening the tall poppy
syndrome which is very endemic this kind
of zero some mentality if you divert
away from doing something that is the
norm you're very quickly sort of shut
down that's stupid that's lame why are
you trying this uh and in the US you
don't quite have that so much now you do
have a problem the us too which is that
children have promised the American
dream and when they grow up to become
adults and they feel like reality hasn't
delivered that to them they often feel a
sense of entitlement why isn't the world
this way and this is why I think that
the victimhood culture seems to be more
patient zeroe over here in the US than
it is in the UK because in the UK what
did you hope for
everyone's like you expect of course
you're a victim yeah you you expected
nothing and nothing came to you
congratulations you achieved your goals
and you know this is a a really
important rule which is the difference
between your expectation and your
reality very much is determinant of how
we feel about our lives you know desire
is the thief of Joy a comparison is the
thief of Joy desire is a contract you
make with yourself to be unhappy until
you get what you want all that it's
doing is comparing where you want to be
to where you are and that's not
necessarily uh a justification for
having low expectations but something
like
um pessimism in practice optimism in
reality something like that would be
would be quite nice like sort of uh High
Hopes low expectations something like
that I think would be kind of cool but
yeah man I I this sort of very virulent
strain of people being Ted down in the
UK I feel and I came up with this idea
with a friend Alex called The Lonely
chapter I think it's really important so
I'll teach you guys about it so on your
journey from being the person that you
are now to the person that you want to
be especially if it's going to make some
sort of a dramatic change between the
two you are going to have to go through
a period where you have changed so much
that you no longer fit in with your old
set of friends but you are currently not
yet developed enough to have developed
the new set of friends right and this is
what we call the lonely chapter and I
think it's very important because all of
the Genesis origin stories of I decided
that the sales job wasn't for me or that
the girlfriend wasn't for me or that the
life or the city wasn't for me so I
decided to go out especially because
that's dominated a lot by America it
seems like a very sort of
smooth Journey from making that decision
in terms of commitment and self-belief
but the realistic experience of this is
that if you want to go from where you
are to where you want to be it's going
to cause you to leave friends behind
you're not going to get the new group
this bit in the middle this lonely
chapter will cause you to be riddled
with self-doubt and you will be
uncertain about your future you will
lack self-esteem and you won't even know
that there's going to be glory on the
other side of it right you don't even
know that it's going to work and that
degree of difficulty isn't a bug it's a
feature right it is built in it's baked
into the experience of going from one to
another and I think that that like
really viscerally understanding okay
this isn't a sign that I'm doing
something wrong this isn't a curse this
is actually baked into the EXP exp
erience of going from where I am to
where I want to be and the friends
saying oh he's on a diet again wonder
how long are you going to stick to this
one oh too good to drink with us I guess
like not coming out tonight I'm going to
stay in and like read your poetry are
you whatever it is that you're doing oh
go and do more paintings bro whatever it
is that you're doing uh I think that
understanding this is part and parcel of
life I think is very important it is
very important and also as well it's
when you're what I notice is that
it happened kind of instantly like my
old life and it may have been because of
the pandemic just seemed to collapse
pretty much over a period of a week and
that was a real shock because you think
to yourself I'm working I'm improving
I'm changing I can keep all of these
balls in the air and then very suddenly
it becomes apparent that you can't and
then everything changes in a way that
you can't predict yeah it's scary man uh
and that discomfort is what causes a lot
of people to go back to their old life
you know uh you guys careers being able
to do The Fringe and however many
hundreds of nights per year on the road
okay well that that's safe to me I have
a community I have people that know me
I've got status I've got esteem within
that I need to let all of that go to
then start at the bottom again in this
new industry that I don't even know if
it's going to work so some of it is risk
tolerance which I really struggle with I
struggle with taking risky decisions um
but yeah moving towards things one step
at a time uh Ryan holiday's got this
great quote where he says uh self-belief
is overrated I prefer evidence yes and
yes just one little step okay can I do
this thing yes I can can I do this thing
yes I can like I was riddled with so
much uncertainty and self-doubt
especially throughout my 20s even though
I distensible achieved some success
which made the self-doubt feel even more
shameful right because I didn't even
have the uh the rampant poverty and and
like you know despondent lifestyle I had
something outwardly that looked like it
was sorted but inwardly felt like I was
chronically unconfident of myself and
yeah that you can really really break
through a lack of confidence by just
doing tiny tiny little things and
keeping promises to yourself and over
time Rogan calls it layers of paint so
each time you just one layer of paint
one layer of paint and it's so gossam a
thin that you never even see it but then
when you turn around after a long enough
time you go that's a big pile of
paint and then it's a mountain and I
find that actually what really helps me
is meditation now I always thought that
these people who were like I meditate I
thought all right mate you're a wanker
right but it actually changes your life
if you meditate in the morning and
exercise on top of that what it actually
teaches you is what you have is the
moment so you're not thinking about the
future obsessing about the future you're
not regretting the past which is
frequently what we do you're just purely
in that moment and if you're in that
moment you can dedicate every single one
of your mental faculties to doing the
thing whatever the thing is which means
that the thing is going to be done to
the highest possible standard that you
can do at that time which means that you
going to improve exponentially and also
you going to keep improving yeah I think
a lot of what we do in
life especially when we have a goal that
we're going toward involves dressing up
not doing the thing mhm right right like
ultimately yes there are ways for me we
both spoke we both trained this morning
we both done like whatever little
routine that we've got and I feel really
really great today but one of the
problems The Perils of over optimization
include someone believing that they can
no longer perform unless they go through
this elaborate routine beforehand the
goal should be for you to be able to
perform whether you're in the middle of
a war zone whether you've not had any
sleep whether you've done whatever right
that I want to be able to work like this
and then build myself off the top of
that with oh I'm great I managed to get
my my morning walk in and I managed to
train and I managed to do all the rest
of it but it's a there's a degree of
fragility that comes with over
optimization because people no longer
feel like they're sufficiently robust to
do this stuff and you know I've got
Andrew hubman coming back on the show
soon and I I'm going to bring it up to
him and say look like you know you've
given a lot of people science-based
tools to improve themselves but again
what did we say about knowing where you
could be versus knowing where you are if
you feel like oh God I didn't get 10
minutes of sunlight in my eyes this
morning my circadian rhythm's going to
be messed up I can't believe my adrenals
are all going to that fear of under
optimization now knowing where you could
be at is a discomfort and I think for a
lot of people that want that control in
their lives that's something that gets
felt so yeah that's a although I love
optimizing and I I love coming up with
ways to be better uh certainly one of
the things I've tried to do over the
last 18 months since I moved to Austin
is like let go of that as well let go of
the need for it to be part of
a routine what is it when uh when
someone a Superstition it's almost like
a Superstition right it's no longer a
performance inhancer that you just feel
it's oh I got to put the right boot on
then the left boot on then touch the
door as I walk out like it's it's a form
of OCD almost yeah a little bit you know
like when you watch that Beckham
documentary and he was saying everything
has to be like this it has to be like
this in this particular way it has to be
structured like this and you know that
can be great in one sense cuz it makes
you feel comfortable but like you just
said yourself it's a complete prison
because then you feel unless you do the
thing whatever the thing is yeah you're
not going to be Optimum so you've
already told yourself that you're not
going to be as effective therefore
you're not going to do the thing well
yeah the the doing the thing is just
that do the thing is something that I
must tweet out about once a week and
it's usually reminded to myself that I
schedule in advance for a time when I
know in my calendar that I'll need to
see it and uh yeah so much of our Lives
involve dressing up not doing the thing
that we know we're supposed to do it's
think about when you've got a bunch of
emails that you don't want to reply to
how ridiculous some of the things that
you start I'll clean the fridge I
haven't cleaned the fridge in six months
why why am I doing that oh it's because
I'm evading these emails right oh I I'll
I'll get another Walkin or I'll have
another coffee or I'll make it I'll
better be hydrated oh there's that one
thing that I need to do before it's like
you're just hiding from the work like no
matter how much you dress it up the work
just needs doing and there's
nowhere to hide from it one thing I want
to come back to what you guys were
talking about just a little bit earlier
is uh you were talking about Burning
Bridges essentially this is why I've
never had a problem Burning Bridges
because it gives you the like there is
no going back to the comedy industry for
me there just isn't you scorched Earth
with that yeah yeah and I have fire and
brimstone fire and brimstone and I did
it on purpose because that's exactly
what I needed to do to make this work
it's just it's just what that's what I
needed to do in my own psychology that's
really interesting I think that it's
very much a quirk of your psychology oh
definitely um that I I've it's been very
rare for me that I've not just let
things sort of slowly slide away you
know the relationships or or the
connections or the places that I would
show up or whatever it is just kind of
dissipated uh and you know it's a lot
less uncomfortable than people might
think because everybody is so wrapped up
in their own existence they've got very
little time to think about yours not in
the comedy industry they don't they've
got loads of time got loads of time and
lots of things to say on social media
the reason I bring it up is I think um
what you said about having to move on
from past relationships past friendship
groups Etc it is so fundamentally true I
mean the stats that you probably know
this better than I do like your income
is the average income of the five Clos
people you spend the most time with Etc
you have
to you're the people who you're going to
be friends with truly are going to be
the people who are on your level
mentally intellect
in every way it's just how it is
otherwise you're not going to be friends
I think there's a better version of that
you are the average of the five friends
you spend the most time with you are the
average of the five podcasts you listen
to the most probably I I genuinely think
that for a good chunk of people
especially the people going through the
lonely chapter you know they will have a
stronger friendship relationship they
will spend more time listening to your
guys' show or huberman's show or Lex's
show or whatever then they will with any
other group of friends you know so you
be careful what you're putting in your
ears I suppose too I got this uh idea of
post content Clarity like post nut
Clarity and um when we consume stuff on
the internet a lot of the time we we
don't really think about it reflectively
it just sort of comes and goes and then
if I was to say to you what were the
last five things you watched on YouTube
You're Going to really struggle and if I
said what were the things you watched on
YouTube first yesterday it's basically
impossible right it just comes and goes
um but really what we should be doing is
watching content that after we've
finished it makes us feel better about
ourselves better about the world more
informed you know like you want to go
outside and and ring a friend and tell
them that you missed it like that's how
I want to feel after content and yeah
not all content can be lovey doy and
there's things that people need to learn
that are uncomfortable I want to feel
better once I've finished consuming
something and I realized that so much of
the content I consumed was
like fast food for my amigdala rather
than Spirulina for my soul right it was
just hijacking me limic in the most
bottom of the brain stem way that it
could I'm like I don't want to I
shouldn't watch this anymore so yeah
post content Clarity if someone that's
listening thinks oh I I'm I feel a bit
uncomfortable after I use my phone maybe
it's the amount of time you're spending
on your phone absolutely but very much I
think you can change what you're
choosing to consume oh definitely and I
would modify that slightly though
because I think I I didn't feel good
after watching Schindler's List but I I
think it was important to watch you know
what I mean so when we have someone on
to we had Maggie Oliver recently to talk
about police corruption and grooming
gangs in the UK we cover those issues
because other media Outlets won't cover
them properly and won't keep that
conversation going I don't know anyone
who do who tuned into that fired up
after that being said the way that you
guys haven't seen that episode but the
way that you guys probably approached it
isn't in some like tribal Lally
hijacking way it's in a luck this is a
really important thing that we need to
be connected to that we're not
sufficiently aware of so even in the
framing of a difficult subject I'm
talking about is any show that begins by
calling out an outg group yeah right if
if any piece of content on the internet
and whether it be a book whether it be a
Creator YouTube
Twitter if that person's group is
fundamentally held together by the
mutual distaste of an outgroup rather
than the mutual love of an ingroup
that's a red flag it's a huge red flag
for me you know I always compare this to
cuz I used to get ecer a lot when I was
a kid scratching your
when you scratch your eczema it feels
better but then you stop and it it's
worse it just makes you more itchy it
makes you more uncomfortable and I think
that's something more and more that
people just need to understand is what
you do in the moment may make you feel
good but later on it's just going to
make you feel worse and I think so many
people they go online and they almost
get
this this almost druglike hit out of
something that will out of a piece of
content that will make them feel
something but then you see them like an
hour afterwards and they're still
ruminating about this thing and it's
just it's completely wrecked the next
couple of hours well think about a
little bit more I guess close to what
some of the subjects that you guys talk
about are the uh desire for performative
empathy that is very prevalent on the
internet what people are actually
optimizing for with performative empathy
or um you should post a black square and
and silence is compliance or violence
you know all of these sort of things
silence is consent that's my favorite
silence like it's Jimmy car in the room
but it's they they had that slogan going
during BLM silence is
consent and I was going have you thought
of applying this to other situations
yeah very dangerous rule um so yeah
sorry s he doesn't know where to go with
that so one of the problems that you
have the reason that I think that this
is tied together is an uh over
prioritization of the present moment of
the now a a fear of discomfort and a
pushing away of it you know given the
fact that there are many problems that
people feel internally their internal
State the existential crisis am I really
living my life in the BET way best way
uh there's something called
intergenerational competition Theory
which is if each generation does better
than their parents then inherently
everyone feels good and you know
Millennials and especially gen Z are
probably one that even m ially has done
worse than their parents so yeah you
comparing yourself to where your parents
were at your age and you're feeling like
you're falling behind on average really
really not great and what does that mean
it means that when you compare that with
a world in which everything can be
convenient and you can Uber Eats
yourself and Mitchel in Star meal while
you sit on a couch you Amazon primed and
watch a Netflix documentary that won an
award you are very bereft of most
immediate discomforts and when you face
them it feels more like a a perversion
of how reality is supp supposed to be
rather than just baked into the
existence of things get hard sometimes
so what I see with the this sort of the
victimhood culture and then also
people's desire or push for performative
empathy is the opposite of not giving
Nikolai your son uh ice cream every
night it's like maybe he's not at the
age he eats ice cream but whatever like
some treat that he would like he would
it would be something he would enjoy but
not be good for him long term but when
people optim the thing that they enjoy
over what is good for them and they
refuse to believe that there can be
anything which is not enjoyable but good
for them you end up with an entire
Society that's basically mentally always
eating ice cream well and when it comes
to food I'm like the use of ice metaphor
it's what Rogan calls mouth pleasure and
I like that he calls it that because
that's what it is you're you're buying a
little bit of pleasure but doing
something that's actually harmful to you
and so many things in life they're not
supposed to be easy they're not supposed
to be pleasant or comfortable and I
always I always say this to people it's
like everything you want is by
definition outside of the comfort zone
that you're in because otherwise you'd
already have it if you could have what
you want by being comfortable you'd have
it now because you you wouldn't need to
you also wouldn't value it yeah right
that's other thing there
is one of the really interesting
realizations is that a lot of the things
that people want to get easily are only
valuable because they're not attainable
with ease right so if you end up trying
to do this if you did dial down the
difficulty of achieving the thing that
you say you want to achieve you would no
longer want it baked into the difficulty
is the value of the thing that's right
yeah and it we don't talk about it
enough and also we talk a lot about
being kind to
ourselves but actually being kind to
yourself means going to the gym when you
don't want to go to the gym not
indulging yourself doing something that
is actually very difficult that you run
away from but you know that you must do
what
if a better definition of self-love
would be holding yourself to a higher
standard than anybody else's yes yes
like what if you are your own biggest
champion yes and then what if having
friends good friends that care about you
are people who believe in you more than
they pity you so that when things get
hard they don't pat you on the shoulder
Lex won't mind me telling the story you
came to malice's house where you guys
had a party this week and I sadly missed
um Lex came and I think maybe the
Ukraine war had just started out and he
was trying to keep an ear on that and
maybe he's going to go out and speak to
Putin or somebody else and he's trying
to build robots and then he's trying to
do his podcast and he's doing all of
these different things and he was
talking about how he was lamenting
juggling all of these plates to some of
his friends or maybe even just somebody
and he said uh a lot of his friends kind
of patted him on the shoulder and said
oh man you work so much already you know
this is like you should be you should go
easier on himself on yourself he turned
and looked at me and he went I wish
people would stop saying that I wish
that they would say yeah this is tough
but you're tougher and I thought wow
that's so cool you know for someone who
seeks in their friends people who
believe in them more than they pity them
yeah uh is just such a and you know the
self Lov self- love is holding yourself
to a higher standard than anybody else
like that is just such a powerful idea
and uh functionally much more useful as
well it is the challenge comes when
you've been raised by parents who you
know cudle you teach you that never had
that
problem teach you that actually you know
you are a victim and for people other
people will sort out your problems other
people will rise to the challenge for
you and that becomes a learned behavior
and I think that what we need to do is
Empower children to make them realize
that that that facing a challenge is
life life is a challenge if you as
somebody who may be a little bit cynical
slightly blackpilled in in any form of
the word whether it be through dating or
personal development or Career
Development or finances or social
Mobility whatever it is that you're
worried about think about how fragile
the average person is and realize that
half of the population is more fragile
than that right a great rewording of I
think it was George Carlin's line think
how stupid the average person is realize
half of them are even stup yeah right so
50% of the 50% of the the population is
more fragile than the average person
that you know and you have to work
really really hard to be able to find
friends that are super robust and anti
fragile and you go oh my God this is
such a rarity okay so what you're
telling me is that the bar is set low I
don't think the bar has ever been set
this low for people to be able to
separate themselves out from the pack
the average American is
obese Divorced with less than 1K in the
bank so taking the path that everybody
else chooses may seem like the safe
option but it's actually a guaranteed
route to a life that you probably don't
want
wow we'll be back with the interview in
one minute first we want to talk to you
about the sponsors of today's episode
ag1 we take ag1 to stay healthy and
Stave off illness whenever our schedule
gets really busy we used it on our last
America Tour where we were constantly on
the Move living out of a bag and working
every day one scoop a day meant we knew
we had all the vitamins and minerals
needed for the day we invested in our
health and had a hugely successful trip
as you saw ag1 is a simple and easy way
to get all the nutrients you need each
serving contains 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients if you're looking for a
simple and cost effective supplement
routine we recommend you try ag1 and
they're giving you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase to claim
them just go to drink a1.com
trigonometry go to drink a1.com
trigonometry that's drink a1.com SL
trigonometry to claim this special
offer that's such a profound Point man
that's such aound point and actually
when uh when Jordan had me on his show
he did this pay section that they do at
the end and he was asking me about my
background whatever and I talked we
talked about when I was homeless in the
secret said
oh uh we talked about when I was
sleeping in a park and I and I told the
story about um I used to smoke back
then and uh I was just I had nothing to
do all day cuz that's what that's what
it is to be homeless and and not to have
a job job at that time Etc I was just
walking around and this guy was waiting
for a bus and he lit a cigarette and I
was oh hell and the bus came so
he got upset dropped the cigarette and I
remember picking that cigarette up and
in that moment it was the lowest that
I've ever felt ever and that was the
moment I decided I'd never I'd never be
there again I'm never coming back here
and he was like that's right when you
want to do things in your life it's
helpful to know the heaven that you're
going to but it's also very useful to
have a hell behind you that you're
moving away from and that's what you're
talking about this is why it's I think
that's such a great reframe because the
the alternative to going for it and
trying things and doing your best and
actually attempting to achieve the thing
you you you're meant to achieve and I
really believe in in in that sense of
Destiny in a way is not comfort and sort
of everything's all right it's
terrible and that that a great reframe
and I love that yeah I you know Dana
White said uh this I love that
guy I know we're both we're both big
we're both big fans of him Dana we're
coming for you
um he had this really great reel that
someone repurposed that said um I I
think he's got Sons uh he yeah uh I I
tell my sons it's all out there for the
taking right now if you have a gram of
talent and an ounce of hard work you'll
run these over and it's like
it's true like there is that the bar has
never been set lower and I understand
you know if you wallow in Reddit and the
dark recesses of Twitter that you can
believe that you are a genetic dead end
as a man and there is nothing that you
can do or as a woman that the culture is
you're kind of at the mercy of the
culture in a way and you maybe feel like
you missed a Time Of Glory or that was
more appropriate for you maybe it was
the the 1950s or maybe it was the
Middle Ages I don't know right
you feel wistful for a life that you
never got to
lead but the the truthful fact is I
don't think there's ever been a time
where there's been more
opportunity and a lower degree of
competition agreed we've just said the
average American that's the average
American right yeah obese less than 1K
in the bank and divorced right like just
it's so low and I I understand that it
can seem like you're talking from an
ivory Tower or well done you had this
sorted but I didn't have it sorted I
didn't have it sorted for a very long
time you know I I I had days where
getting one foot out of my bed onto the
floor was a task so great that I
couldn't do it right that I just
couldn't bear to open the curtains I
couldn't bear to speak to anybody and
ostensively outside I had the entire
life sorted okay so what does that tell
you tells you that material conditions
don't actually always determine your
internal state so don't presume that the
things that you're chasing for are
actually going to fix whatever your
internal problem is and also don't use
your external State as an excuse for the
way that your internal feelings are
that's not to say that you can't get get
to a state of destitution where it's
pretty much impossible to be happy but
you we all know what you mean you know
the one thing that I worry about is
having having
kids uh and I'm sure the two of you will
have kids at some point as well is how
do you pass like you we were talking
earlier before we started about like
you're a dog you were saying this to me
like you you you you have really high
stand it's true I do and that's partly
because like I've been right at the
bottom and I'm never going back there
I'm just not but how do you pass that on
to somebody who your entire Mission you
think is to provide a great life for I
love this absolutely I love this
question and I've asked it to a lot of
successful young dudes who've got young
kids Ben Francis uh CEO of Jim Shar his
net worth is three times Drakes right
he's triple the net worth of Drake like
2.5 2 something mil billion sorry um uh
Ryan Terry another guy both workingclass
backgrounds uh Ben francis's grandfather
Works still works I think in like some
smelting place in Birmingham like it's
peaky blinders and then uh you
would it would have been enough just to
say Birmingham mate yeah true uh then
Ryan
Terry's dad and then him both plumbers I
think like really bad plumbers he's a
bad plumber According to some friends
and
um both of them really really valued the
lessons that their working class
upbringing gave them you know really
like spit and sawdust and and you like
eat what you kill type
mentality and yet what was the point in
working this hard if you're not going to
give your progyny the benefits that you
have worked for like what was the point
of doing this yeah there's Legacy and
impact and all that sort of stuff but
presumably the greatest impact you want
to have is on the the people that have
your genetics right your kids the people
you care about the most okay so tell me
how are you going to balance this I want
them to learn the lessons of things
being hard with I want to be able to
afford them the opportunities that I
never had and I these two worlds I
genuinely don't know how they they fit
together I I don't know how easily they
do I guess this is going to be a
challenge that you're going to have to
face in some regards as well but I know
for a fact that Ryan pulled his kid out
of private school his kid was going to a
private school I think he's maybe only
like three or four a preschool private
school something and uh like there was
like a nonzero number of children that
arrive by helicopter each day so kids
like just getting dropped off by
presumably the nanny or the
assistant or whatever it is ushed off
and then they'll they'll fly away and he
was like I I just can't I couldn't I
couldn't do it I couldn't I didn't like
the work ethic of this particular school
by helicopter by helicopter that
school's like a
factory just stamping them out one
guaranteed we're not going to get
monetized on this episode B that out we
won that sweet sweet advertising dollar
Kevin Hart has got a great story about
this obviously Kevin Hart came from a
really I think it's Chicago really poor
part of Chicago really desperate poverty
there made his way to
Hollywood comedic super comedy Superstar
and he said to his kids right I want you
to understand where I came from I want
you to understand Daddy's struggle I
want you to understand how daddy worked
I'm going to take you back to where
daddy came from so he took him to what
he calls a ghetto showed them round they
did a two hours they went and met people
and he went right what do you think and
they both went we love the
ghetto and he's like no that's not what
you were supposed to take from this
because yeah because to them it's
novelty ah it's novelty and the the the
worst part about growing up in that
place isn't that you grow up in that
place it's this knowledge that chances
are you ain't going to leave it's the
difference it's fundamentally the
difference between going camping or
being homeless yes yeah right one is a
choice the the other is a necessity it's
homeless face yeah it's it's like
homeless
face was it Christopher Hitchens that
got water boarded on or Peter Hitchens
one of them it was Christopher who got
Christopher Peter did by Alex o
Conor that will be out soon from what I
gather or by the time this has gone out
or did he water board himself by the
time this has gone out this will be
super everyone will know that'll be old
news but yeah Christoph Hitchens was
like let's check if it's torture go and
get water board and I'm like you can
stop it at any time and you know it's
going to end it's completely not the
same thing yeah yeah yeah so how you do
that with kids probably not water
boarding but short of that is how do you
create that um and I genuinely don't
know get
divorced that would teach that'll teach
him you've got the material conditions
but you're going to be bereft of Love
yeah exactly Daddy doesn't love you
here's your por ah no um no I don't know
because and I think your point about
Kevin Hart and going to the ghetto is
that reality is you have to have
difficult experiences and this is a big
source of tension between my wife and I
cuz and for women it's like she's
carried him inside her for nine months
and then he literally fed from her
breast for however many years and after
that you want him to go and get smashed
over the head by life yeah that's
hard especially when you have
the opportunity to stop it right but on
the other hand if you've been smashed in
the face by
life how are you going to deal with the
inevitable fact that life will smash you
in the face doesn't matter if you're a
billionaire life will smash someone's
going to die someone's going to get
injured some accident's going to happen
you're going to get a disease your
business might fail your business might
fail someone's going to leave you Global
pandemic happens Global pandemic
anything you're going to get smashed in
the face by life there's no getting away
from it right and it's probably not
helpful that the first time that truly
happens is when you're 30 it's probably
not helpful because you want a little
bit of like life smashing you in the
face when you're a kid so you know how
to deal with it how do you build
resilience without without being tested
yeah I I've thought about this a good
bit I I was quite heavily bullied when I
was a kid and I was an only child and I
didn't fit in and what I realized
reflecting on that experience which I
held as a chip on my shoulder for a long
time like I prove these people wrong or
just like resentment or bitterness or or
still feeling like they were right about
me right that they had some sort of
perfectly balanced insight into me the
first thing I realized was I probably
should stop caring about what other
people think about me given that most
people don't even like
themselves right most people don't even
like themselves why on Earth would you
give anybody else that power secondly
the blame finger wherever you point the
blame this is why I am the way I am
that's the same place that you point the
power right oh right okay so the reason
that I don't have confidence in myself
is because of Tom at school so I
guess Tom's opinion of me is more
important than my desire to have
confidence third thing this is from Rick
from Rick and Morty uh he walks into
this big um like rock festival that it's
kind of like a Tony Robins thing but
it's an alien obviously this alien and
he walks in and everyone starts going
boo boo Rick boo he turns around and he
says your booze mean nothing I've seen
what makes you cheer you go oh my God
it's such a mic drop my point being I
went through this period of thinking
like right okay I'm kind of at the mercy
of these people's opinions I've got this
chip on my shoulder all of these things
I've been held back by even the negative
experiences but when I look at so many
of the things that I care about and I
value in myself now they're the light
side of the dark stuff that I developed
in that in any case like the only reason
that I was able to move make the move to
America on my own to see if this thing
would work is because I'm so used to
Solitude because I was so lonely
as a kid right the only reason that I
pay so much attention to the different
things that are going on into
conversations is that I obsessed over
why other people had friends and I
didn't when I was in school I used to
believe that it was because of the
particular way that they tied their tie
or the type of shoes they had or or they
carry their bag on their left shoulder
and I carry my bag on my right shoulder
that's why right so I was so I just
couldn't understand why other people had
friends and I didn't so I spent so long
obsessing and
deconstructing them even though I I
wasn't purposefully doing it was just
like a byproduct of wanting to be wanted
and wanting to be a part of something
and I roll the clock forward and I think
so much of my childhood was spent
listening to story tapes in my room
playing on my own what's the 2023 qu of
a story tape it's a podcast like I'm
still doing I'm still that kid in my
room I've just got to do I've got to do
it on my own terms now so I when we're
talking about difficult situations would
I go back and say save me from those
experiences that's a really hard comment
because I know I suffered I know that it
was uncomfortable I know I was sad I
know it made my parents sad for me to be
sad I know they felt like it reflected
on them somehow that I wasn't able to
connect and I wasn't happy with kids and
stuff like that and yet there's no way
that I would have managed to get to the
point that I'm in a life that I really
value had I not have done that so I
think we should be cautious around the
impact of bad and good things uh and
this is one of the reasons that I really
don't like people that use the word like
it was meant to be because it completely
removes the agency from the situation
okay you get into a car accident you
lose one of your legs and you meet the
love of your life who's the nurse that
treats you uh while you're in the
hospital bed you get married and you
live a lovely life together it was meant
to be had it not been for that accident
I would have never met the love of my
life okay how about this you were in a
shitty situation and you managed to
alchemize it from lead into gold you
managed to turn something that could
have been a destitute situation into one
that was that was beautiful and one of
the most important things that happened
in your life and that's a much more
powerful story and I think internalizing
this locus of control super important
and not being too concerned about
I'm going through something bad all
right who this is maybe your hero story
right like this is main character energy
fuel for you agreed yeah and it's
interesting what you made the point
about only child because I'm an only
child as well and I think with only
children we spend so much time on our
own that we tend to go one of two ways
which is the because you in a sense
undersocialized you either
become more of a loner or you become
hypers social which is what I did and
that's where the humor came from so and
also things going on when I was growing
up I got very very good at walking into
a room testing seeing what the
atmosphere was like and knowing how to
diffuse it quickly all the time all the
time all the time now people say God
well that's not healthy a kid shouldn't
have that a kid shouldn't be you know
experiencing that on a day-to-day basis
probably not but actually what he has
given me is the ability to walk into a
room I'm a very very good judge of
character I look at people I can what I
got to be vigilant for so long yeah so
you have to be vigilant for so long and
you know when there's a tension in the
room or something happens bam you can
say something laughter it calms it down
do you find yourself people pleasing yes
yeah me too a lot I I work all day every
day to try
to that from my personal I've only
learned about this about myself over the
last month or so so it's this is like my
new thing you know like that uh um
availability bias like the thing that
you've learned about you just bought the
car and now you see the car everywhere
this is like my mental model that I've
just learned about myself and now I'm
seeing it everywhere but yeah people
pleasing that people pleasing nature
comes from it um I it's so interesting
to think about you deconstructing a room
and going in and realizing okay exactly
like what am I attuned to and then like
playing that game it's kind of like um
speedrunning likeability or growth
hacking resonance right that's what
you're doing and although it sounds
great what it can end up and it what it
did for me was I got toward the end of
my 20s and the Persona had subsumed the
person mhm right I I was playing this
role so so frontward facing that felt
discordance with who I was really
and I would run these club nights I've
met like a million people people on the
front door of nightclubs and run a
thousand events across my career as a
club promoter and I loved my business
partner I loved all the guys that I
worked with but I'd met a million people
and had a handful of friends right so my
funnel of friend exposure to conversion
ratio there was something off there and
there was a period especially toward the
end of my career where I would set the
club away and I would make sure that the
boys were happy and like all the
managers and stuff that we had working
for us and then I'd go and sit in my car
and I'd like watch School of Life
videos how was I not not screaming to
myself like this is obviously you there
is a discordance in the force or like
there is a murmuring and whatever the
Star Wars reference is it wasn't right
and it wasn't right because I despite
being in a
crowd I felt lonely and despite having
Victory I often felt Hollow so it's like
yeah if you don't have that resonance
and there's something again to kind of
hammer it home there's something
particularly shameful about knowing that
other people have it way worse than you
in terms of their material situation and
you're
still upset or unfulfilled or whatever
because there's no glory
in I know there's not much glory in
picking up somebody else's cigarette
butt off the ground but there's
something that feels like it's actual
rock bottom right there's something
there it doesn't feel as like Bourgeois
and high futing like oh the
existential weight of living bro like am
I enacting my Logos and the shame that
you layer on top of yourself may be
almost as much as the shame of of
picking up someone else's cigarette off
the ground absolutely you mentioned the
word lonely a lot and one of the things
that you talk a lot about and interview
people a lot about and think a lot about
and you and I have talked about this
privately as well
is um the dating situation and the men
and women situation at the moment um and
when you had me on your show you sort of
playfully accused me of giving tra tra
talking
points I probably am a tradcon to be
honest when it comes to that that sort
of thing U but I'm also open to the
possibility that well it's not a
possibility it's a reality that I'm 40
years old I've been married since I was
20 I may not know all about it yeah so
um what's going on am I the canary and
the co mine yeah it's uh I don't mean
with you person yeah I understand why
aren't you married yeah yeah make
children now we need your genetics yeah
um
it's very fascinating it's a very
interesting time for dating I think it's
probably by far the most interesting
time for for human mating dynamics that
there's ever been um because and and
this is shown in how many people are
talking about this on the internet even
though it's largely still a subculture
and a lot of people are trying to
deconstruct exactly why is it that
marriage rates are down and birth rates
are down and coupling is down and
happiness is down and all of these sorts
of things and um there's a bunch of
different flavors of what's happening so
I think before you even get to the topic
talking about who's talking about the
topic is kind of important
because I have to wipe a lot of
manosphere slime off me yes before I
have to counter signal with and I'm not
saying and we must remember that women
are able to and I have to like prostrate
myself on the like crucifix of
I'm not a bigot before I can get to my
talking point right my point being both
sides as far as I can see the big broad
buckets that would be kind of like
whatever the newest wave of Tik Tok
feminism Boss culture is and the
manosphere breaking into red pill and
black pill like positive view uh
transactional and uh negative view like
um
avoidant both of them I think are
missing the point here which is largely
Chris before you delve into it just
Define a little bit more for people who
are maybe fresh to the conversation red
pill and black pill the black pill is
the incel type stuff where with drawing
we're not going to connect with them the
red pill is a little bit more difficult
cuz it's a broad church it's there's
many people that that class themselves
as that so yeah um it's from The Matrix
the red pill is seeing the truth the
blue pill is kind of living the lie so
in dating hierarchy blue pill is guy
doesn't understand how mating Dynamics
work they don't understand that women
have a hypergamous nature where they
want to date up and across
socioeconomically they don't understand
they believe kind of in the one true
itis one true love thing it's this sort
of Renaissance delusion that they have
in a little bit of a way about kind of
like Sacred Love um then taking the red
pill would be seeing the world for what
it is but in between those two is the
purple pill which is people who know the
truth but refuse to accept it that's
what I get accused of being a lot
somebody who still has uh that is in
seen by the manosphere as being too uh
pliable when it comes to not pointing
the finger at women which is
because I'm so bigoted uh that I'm a
misogynist to Guardian readers but I'm
so cooked that I'm like a purple pill
wanker to the manosphere people so I
managed to split the difference you're a
dating Centrist ah yeah so the red pill
would be uh people seeing the world as
it truly is uh that is understanding
mating Dynamics understanding that women
are fundamentally attracted to Super
Chad at the top and that they're going
to leave the guy that they're with if a
better option comes along so on and so
forth and then the black pill at the
bottom would be they would see it as
being even more true truthful like the
black pill the self-identified black
pill guys genuinely see their worldview
as being more accurate than the red pill
and in some ways it actually is but the
net result of the black pill is very
much often uh super avoidant um uh
relationships specifically with women uh
mgtow men going their own way is a part
of this uh a lot of those guys are men
who have been in relationships and maybe
suffered with uh Divorce Court
separation uh some of them are people
who've just had a lack of uh success
with women generally but the main reason
that it's interesting is you have a huge
Changing of the Guard socioeconomically
between men and women you know
fundamentally I think the biggest change
that's occurred has been liberating
having sex from making babies and women
entering the workforce those two things
changed the dynamic of mating forever
because before that marriages stuck
together and no one wants to talk about
very few people want to talk about this
many marriages stuck together because
the wife was essentially like a
financial prisoner of their husband if
you can't support yourself and
potentially loads of children as well
guess what you're staying in that
marriage no matter what happens then the
pill comes along and liberates women
from having to have children with men
that they didn't want to interestingly
I'm sure you've spoken to Mary
Harrington about this it increased the
number of single mothers the
introduction of the pill increased the
number of single mothers because prior
to the pill
a man getting a woman pregnant was seen
as his responsibility and after the pill
as her choice right you could have been
on the pill okay so now we've decoupled
having sex from making babies the next
thing we need to do is decouple this
like pesy historic vestigal attachment
that women have so even though the
having sex and the making babies has
been separated they still it's it's
frustrating they keep on getting
attached to these men that they have sex
with so we need another technology which
which is a cultural technology and that
one is sex positive feminism you can
like true Liberation for women is
working like your father and having sex
like your brother right that's truly
what it means to be and you can be free
to do it as much as you want articles in
Cosmopolitan I know Louise Perry talks
about this like how to sleep with him
and not catch feels basically how to
disembody yourself from doing something
that previously was seen as sacred so
we've used all of this and what it's
resulted in is an awful lot of men who
feel like they're invisible to women an
awful lot of women who feel used and
discarded by men that they Pine after or
struggle to find men that are
sufficiently mature and both sexes
continue to move further apart this is
reflected in uh the numbers on dating
it's a huge percentages of men under the
age of 18 to 30 like 60 70% of men aged
18 to 30 aren't in any kind of committed
or longterm relationship like nearly
half of men in that age bracket say
they're not looking for it 45 % of men
aged 18 to 25 have never approached a
woman huge it's just it's two broad
buckets of people that have very little
interest in trying to talk to each other
whether it's because of fear or
avoidance can I go full tradcon hereit
never go full tradcon but I I always
thought and I know this is not a
fashionable view but I don't give a
the the point of dating is to find that
romantic blue one true love for you
right and then form a bond and then stay
together for the rest of your lives um
that does not preclude me from
recognizing that men and women are
different and many of the things that
red peel people say about relationships
between men and women are simultaneously
true so you can be in a relationship
where it's your one true love and
recognize that your wife will want you
to earn more money than her and that in
certain situations she'll want you to
lead and in other situations she'll this
and blah blah blah blah blah what's
wrong with that worldview nothing
nothing and this is why I agree with
many of the many of the things that are
put forward by guys that are in the red
pill the main issue that I take with the
red pill is not the Insight around
evolutionary psychology which is is is
largely accurate hypogamy is a genuine
thing uh women prefer a man that is
decisive women date up and across
socioeconomically uh my main concern my
main issue is that they treat women like
an adversary to be used and discarded or
avoided entirely but but that ignores
the first part of what I said which is
your the point of dating is to find your
one true love blue pill style right
what's wrong with that is there anything
wrong with that nothing in particular I
don't think so I mean if you I I I I
certainly do think that if you take the
genuine red pill which goes all the way
down which
is humans evolutionarily weren't wired
to be monogamous for life was were wired
to be serially monogamous monogamish
it's called which is why many couples
will feel a 3 to seveny year itch uh
it's a very difficult period for a
relationship to get to why well it's
because around about that time the child
is sufficiently grown that the man can
move on or the the mother can move on to
another partner it seems like that is
the way that we are evolved to be for a
very very long time it would have been
just straight up polygyny and then it
pivoted into this sort of Serial
monogamy thing so a genuinely
uncomfortable red pill is that we are
fighting our Natures by having lifelong
commitments but we have an awful lot of
control over the way that we feel and
when you weigh up do I want to be 40 47
54 61 still getting back out there onto
the market because I can is that really
the life that you want to lead and I
think on balance you you end up in a
worse position as a man like make no
mistake marriage for men is one of the
best deals that you can get from a
physiological perspective married men
live so much longer than single men the
problem that gets put forward is divorce
courts are really prejudiced against men
as our uh child whatever it's called
like whoever who custody child custody
courts too so you're rolling the dice so
the argument against the the red pill
argument against your blue pill
oneitis Viewpoint would be yeah that's
all great well and good but only if you
thread the needle through this mindfield
of potential risks half your money's
gone and you're never going to see your
kid and blah blah blah and this many per
of marriages end in divorce so it's a
bad deal for men uh but again as soon as
you move that to college educated men
everything changes as soon as you move
that to people who have got U like at
least quasi religious uh worldview that
changes again you can stack a number of
worldviews on top that actually helps to
to get those numbers to change but it's
a it's a mess at the moment and there
also there's this thread I've seen in
modern women of missandry which is you
know all men are bastards M I heard that
I remember towards the end of my time in
the comedy industry where women used to
drop that literally in front of you just
got yeah all men are B who's that
Australian comedian lady that's not not
a comedian Hannah Hannah gadsby thank
you yeah her yeah and I I was just and I
just used to listen to this and everyone
was like yeah they are or you know they
just used to brush it off and I I I just
found that apph horen is that your world
viiew is that the way you see the world
and then you yet you go on stage or that
you talk to your mates and you complain
how old men are bastards and yet you're
single do you not see why there is a
kind of mismatch here yeah well I mean
the women who are saying in the same
sentence that men control the world and
have everything sorted and are also all
bastards but where are all of the Good
Men at are committing like dating logic
sepu right you're going okay the exact
dir of eligible partners that you're
complaining about is facilitated by the
lack of sympathy that you're giving that
helps to raise men up like make no
mistake men are really really struggling
at the moment like a man under the age
of 40 the single biggest risk to his own
life is his own hand M right why 1990
the average number of close friends that
a man could call on in an emergency the
percentage of men that said it was Zero
was 3% 30 years later in 2020 it's 15%
it's 5x right the most common answer to
the question how many friends do you
have is zero right it's not the average
but it's the most common answer more men
say they have zero friends to call on in
a situation that would be an emergency
than any other number it's
terrifying and yet yeah the punching up
punching down thing men have been in
this position of power for sufficiently
long therefore we can continue to push
back and I it's just it's childish
thinking it's not realistic it doesn't
reflect the experience of almost all of
the men I think that are suffering and a
lot of men are being made or they feel
like they're being made to pay for the
benefits of a patriarchy that they no
longer are a part of right
that their fathers and grandfathers got
an
advantage that they no longer are and
yet they're still having the finger
pointed at them and they go well look
like I haven't been able to get a girl
to go on a date with me for however long
we're just clipping
that good rightly so that being said and
you know this is this is why it's very
difficult to kind of get this point
across perfectly well because it's
nuanced I can say many men are suff
suffering and it is really really hard
and we need to give them sympathy and in
the same breath I think that many men
have a victimhood complex and that
they're too cynical and negative about
the world I think that many men would
benefit if they had a more internal
locus of control all of the stuff that
we talked about in the first well this
is what I was going to say is is it
sympathy that men need or do we need to
be that friend that goes you're stronger
than this you're better than this
there's never been a lower bar there's
never been a situation where it's been
easier for you to stand out sympath this
was the point I was making on your show
and we were having it back and forth
about because ultimately like when I
look at my son I'm not scared of his
future because if I can I'm going to
teach him this is the moment in which
it's never been easier to stand out one
of the problems at least that some guys
would say is that's all well and good
for you it's somebody that's a learned
well-rounded father I didn't have that
father this generation I didn't have
that father either true and my father
didn't have a father at all right so
well you have to be a Breakwater at some
point uh a Breakwater at some point
right it's like um one of my friends
Cory Allen he does he's meditation coach
and a lot of the time when he sees
somebody that's angry he sees that anger
and wonders where is that Trace back to
who gave it to the person they gave it
to the person they gave it to the person
they gave it to you uh and I asked
Goggins this you know like David gogins
had this Tyrant of a father you like
really abusive awful awful guy and I
asked him you know do you see part of
your mission in life to be a circuit
breaker for this
generational aggression and and
mistreatment of K and he's got a
daughter and he said yeah like you know
that's a big part of what drives me so I
I I don't disagree but yeah so men
absolutely maybe encouragement rather
than sympathy would be or or belief
would be better but on that point 45% of
of men aged 18 to 25 have never
approached a woman it's like even more
for 18 to 30 that haven't approached a
woman in the last year it's up above 50%
I think okay if not getting a partner is
the thing that is that makes you feel
really bad about
yourself it doesn't matter how much you
think that the world is out to get you
and all of these problems and culture
and feminism and all of this stuff like
dude you're not doing anything about it
like you haven't approached a woman in
the last year what did you expect they
just Walt through the living room it's
fundamentally not going to happen
through your parents living room yeah
but it's like you have to you have to be
out there and you have to be doing
things and be excited about things and
be creating things like I'm married but
I have no I don't have that many
problems like meeting interesting women
who would date me if I were single cuz
I'm out in the world doing stuff you
know what I mean that's really the
dancer I think finding a partner that
you admire
is just such a a amazing heris that
Downstream from it almost everything
because admiration runs you can admire
somebody that's really great with people
you know that's really nurturing and
caring you can admire someone that's
really competent at a sport admire
someone that's really dextrous with
their thoughts admire someone that's
really virtuous and tells the truth many
different ways that you can find someone
to to admire and ultimately your goal
should be to craft yourself into someone
that is admirable right as opposed to
trying to this was fundamentally the
problem with the pickup artist movement
so pickup Artistry in sort of the 2006
issues when the game came out from Neil
Strauss and it had maybe about eight
years or so of like
really high popularity they used neural
linguistic programming and a bunch of
other kind of interpersonal tools to be
able to get women to go to bed with men
that they otherwise wouldn't have done
and the problem with pickup Artistry was
it taught men that the person they
needed to be in order to get women to
sleep with them was so far away from the
person that they were naturally that it
made them despondent in fact fact the
original I think the original migt black
pill subreddit was called like red pill
uh uh Pua hate RPA hate because it was
men who had been through that and had
either found out that it didn't work for
them which made them super despondent or
found out that it did work for them and
they were so distraught at oh my God
this is what these these they
don't like me for me even though I can
do it I'm not that person and again we
were talking about you know the Persona
subsuming the person it's very
uncomfortable when you realize the world
wants this and I am this and oh my God
what do I do about it yeah
and that is such a profound point
because if you feel that the world only
wants this from you and you're this and
what you're essentially perceiving is
that you have no value unless you lie
and that's a pretty desperate place to
be aubre Marcus guy that founded on it
with Rogan taught me this on the first
ever episode that we did it stuck with
me such a good quote he said the Persona
is incapable of receiving love it can
only receive praise and I think that
this is precisely how you feel alone in
a crowd and holl in Victory because if
you're only playing a role people aren't
applauding you it doesn't ever hit you
right emotionally viscerally on an
existential level what it feels like is
well done reading that script right
right not you it doesn't ever hit you
and this was the sort of vacuousness I
think that at least contributed in my
20s to me being like done the love
Island thing kind of like the you know
Championship League final of Champions
League final of being a boy and
like I've done it and still nothing
right there's still no there there uh
because I there was nowhere else for me
to go on that Journey beyond that and
then I thought I thought this was
going to be the thing and it wasn't the
thing um but yeah rolling into this I
think online dating's done an awful lot
of damage uh there's certainly very poor
outcomes for both men and women on
online dating uh women it's unpopular to
say this because it seems like women's
issues aren't issues of scarcity they're
issues of abundance just the very wrong
kind of abundance but if you want to see
what it's like to be a normal woman on
many dating apps and just get them to go
through their message requests you'll
see just how like awful and juvenile
many men can be and it doesn't need to
be even most men right it only needs to
be a relatively small cohort that smears
the rest and this is the whole like uh
Not all men but always a man thing falls
down because it misses the fundamental
point that sex offenders it's one man in
a thousand doing a thousand things not a
thousand men doing one thing each this
is David bus's work from bad men such a
small number of men are are predators in
that way and yet they commit such a huge
number of of uh incidents and also
they're so disproportionately painful
and these news stories you know quite
rightly cycle
around I mean here's another thing
there's something called gamma bias from
John Barry have you heard about this
before okay so this is really
interesting it's kind of something that
once you see you can't unsee
it in the media if women if a woman does
anything positive it will be sexed if a
woman does something negative it will be
desexed if a man does something positive
it will be desexed if a man does
something negative it will be sexed so
Sarah everad is uh killed by a British
police officer as she's walking home
maybe 5 years ago something like that
and it is all over the press and quite
rightly so it's horrific and there are
placards in the street and people
walking we do not feel safe on our
Shores and we should not be made to men
blah blah blah blah blah right one week
later a man drowns saving a woman
jumping into the temps so he jumps in
saves her and
dies Londoner dies saving uh like
somebody right so the sex of both of
those were
hidden Sarah everard case police man
kills innocent woman and what you get is
this skew which I really don't think is
very beneficial to women either
that the world is a scary place these
gym Tik Tok videos right where girls are
doing a glute bridge and in the
background a dude glances over three
times in 90 seconds and she says this is
uh predatory behavior the male gays
toxic male gaze there was even a thing
on the London Underground I think you
weren't men were told that they
shouldn't look at women for longer than
some amount of time or else that was
predatory I'm pretty sure that Netflix
has got a policy that you're not allowed
to have your eyes linger for more than a
certain amount of time too so they're
really trying to like Nerf down the male
gaze and see it as something that's
that's really really concerning now that
video ended up the big video on Tik Tok
maybe two years ago ended up with most
of the internet saying that's out of
order to the woman right that this poor
man is in the background of your video
and you've used him for clout I don't
think that what he did was predatory but
if you shown me the video in isolation
and not shown me the comments and said
how do you think this was perceived it
would have been a coints for me to go it
could have gone either way I could have
seen this guy get INF flamed yeah he's a
predator all men blah blah blah this is
unacceptable Behavior but here's a
really important thing a situation like
that happens which is a cultural flash
point Downstream from that many women
will use that as a formative experience
to set a bar for what they should and
should not see as acceptable behavior
from men had that have happened many
women would have then gone into the gym
and said if a man glances at me more
than three times in 907 seconds that
means that he's being a pervert and I
should feel unsafe which is kind of like
a one-way street that permanently makes
women more and more fearful of the world
more a sense of vulnerability a
victimhood mentality and forget the fact
that it pushes them further apart from
men just their felt sense of life is
much more scared they ambient anxiety
all the time because this is going on
and this shows up in sort of the post me
to dating World which is kind of a
difficult needle to thread but I'll see
if I can do it
so 86% of women say they want a man to
make the first move 74% of men say that
they are afraid of making a first move
for being seen as creepy 20% of gen Z
say that a man approaching a woman
always or usually constitutes harassment
and 50% of 18 to 30 men haven't
approached a woman in the last year so
let's Square this circle right women
want to be approached but are scared of
being approached men know that if they
don't do the approaching nothing is
going to happen but if they do they may
be going to make women feel
uncomfortable and potentially be part of
some met to Scandal there's some good
cohort of young people that believe that
any approach from a man is basically
unacceptable and yet the outcomes from
online dating aren't particularly good
either so this is a very uncomfortable
realization that I think me too sought
to sanitize the toxic elements of male
behavior and instead it just sterilized
all of
it so that all being the case Chris what
advice would you give young men
nowadays first thing would be find a
group of people near you that want to
grow and want to change especially for
the people that are in the UK I think
that's very important because again as
we said the tall poppy syndrome thing
can drag you down the internet is a
negative enough place already so find a
group of people that want to grow with
you and make the make the statement
almost public like like a CREDO between
you right like this is we are here
because we know that we all want to try
and make this progress together maybe
it's one friend maybe it's a couple of
friends I would be hesitant about making
it a very big group because someone will
drag that group down so I would keep
keep the circle small uh that would be
the first thing the second thing would
be trying to overcome approach anxiety
there's some really great science-based
tools like cognitive behavioral therapy
the guy that created CBT made it for
overcoming his approach anxiety that's
what it was actually designed for in the
first that's fascinating yeah so it's
purpose built for precisely this problem
uh on top of that realize again how low
the bar is set 45% of men 18 to 25 have
never approached a woman around about
50% of men 18 to 30 haven't in the last
year okay so that means that for you to
approach a woman you are already 51
percentile 51st percentile right of all
of the guys if you do that once a year
okay bar is set low great um I think
that there's something interesting for
women here that they can if they want to
be approached uh receptivity is
something that I would I would probably
try and promoting them you've heard
about like the the handkerchief a woman
would drop her handkerchief right in the
like the aristocratic world in the UK in
Britain why would that happen well it's
because it gives the man like an
opportunity it's like an inn it gives
him permission as well yeah precisely so
you know if as a woman you're thinking
why is it that guys aren't approaching
me that much more well maybe trying like
if there's a dude in the bar that you
like like let your eyes Linger on him a
bit more you you cannot overestimate how
dumb some guys are especially ones that
are scared of women from these kinds of
signals so being a bit more forthcoming
again for both men and women go to a
place where your skills are valued and
your uh qualities are valued so if you
played uh tennis in college to a
moderate standard you're probably going
to be better than almost anybody at
pickle ball within two months right so
maybe join a pickle ball especially if
you like hot uh guys and girls that are
athletic and wear shorts and go outside
and get a tan and stuff if that's your
sort of person crack on or if you've got
an interest in ancient Eastern
philosophy find a book club wherever it
is like you want to inhabit places that
have people like the person that you
want to date inhabiting and then a final
thing would be the sex ratio is very
important so in any local ecology the
rarer sex always has the power so if if
you are a woman at
MIT guess what you get to determine the
rules of the game if you are a man at
some liberal arts college guess what you
get to determine the rules of the game
this isn't an argument for me to say
move your career around but certainly
you know if you live in a city I think
New York is very heavily skewed toward
women there's other cities that are very
heavily skewed toward men if you're
really serious about this and you want
to become an intentional dater and try
and find someone to build a life with
it's a small price to pay right go to a
place find that be certain that you're
going to be able to then make the life
work once you found the person but that
will be a final thing for everybody
right like date
intentionally right you just no one
presumes that their career is just going
to fall into their lap no one presumes
that they they have to turn up to work
and acquire skills and qualifications
and they go to college or university for
years to be able to do this and yet we
just presume that Serendipity will give
us our partner it's like I think that a
bit more intentionality would probably
be useful Chris it's been an absolutely
super to you thank you for coming on the
show and join us on locals where you get
to ask Chris your questions and we're
going to talk even more fascinating
things but before that we do always ask
our last question Chris which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about
that we really should be birth rate
decline we are talking about it yeah but
not many people are not many people are
yeah yeah get dating I need said get
shagging get shagging make some babies
people make some babies don't use
protection what well you want babies
I
mean
sure it's a great way to sign
off of the people you've interviewed who
calls you to change your mind or to Al
your outlook the
[Music]
most